women are supposed to do chores around
the house they absolutely are and look
at guys I understand that women we are
not going to come in perfect most women
are not raised to be wives and mothers
we're not if you were born in the 1920s
maybe you were but it's been a 100 Years
of feminist propaganda shoved down our
throats that is not typical traditional
women are rare I I've interviewed
thousands of women I honestly think
maybe one I could point to and say she
was traditional if I really thought
about it maybe five they're they're not
the norm but we can't even admit what we
are supposed to do in a relationship
it's like imagine applying or or imagine
trying out for the NBA and you can't
even admit that you have to shoot a
basket you know that that's part of your
duties and your responsibilities as
women and women we just we just want
everything handed to us we just want
these handouts and we want a free ride
for a lifetime